now Saturday night proved that the only
thing worse than New Year's Eve on CNN
hosted by drunk anchors was New Year's
Eve on CNN with sober anchors
now we at Fox we didn't need booze
hounds to make our coverage on on air
fun it was fun to watch well certainly
not with Jimmy fell on our air joining
us now the host of fox Across America
Fox News Radio he joins us Jimmy now uh
it's great to see you happy New Year now
it wasn't the CNN though host right who
blacked out this time but their actual
coverage I want you to watch what
happened when the clock actually struck
12 in New Orleans
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can see the little countdown on the
corner it wasn't until 19 seconds after
midnight yeah that he asked if everybody
was ready to start the countdown well
it's just 19 seconds it's only a count
now doing the countdown at all Don Lemon
did such a good job Laura they just
offered him a show on CNN Plus
like like man come on dude you literally
had you know the expression you had one
job this is like the groundhog
forgetting to come out of its hole dude
New Year's Eve is all about the
countdown the only thing I'll say in
their defense is CNN has been dropping
the ball all year long oh hey
hey let's drop the mic now uh
Cindy I I've heard when they drank I
think it was a much more interesting or
maybe it's because I wasn't drinking I
don't know who knows
um by the way there's a brand new book
out that's revealing that Biden
apparently doesn't trust his own secret
service saying that he told a friend
that he thought an agent lied about
being bitten on the leg last year by the
then first dog major the president's
attitude about the dog incident
reportedly is part of a broader distrust
of the security agency by the main
figure it's supposed to protect Jimmy
that's his problem with the uh Secret
Service
well he has a territorial thing with the
dogs in the white house because Biden
thinks the only one sniffing people is
him he doesn't realize he has some
competition in that department but yeah
when it comes to the Secret Service if
anybody should be showing their
appreciation it's the guy who needs them
to help him in and out of every room so
he doesn't get lost do you remember when
he was given the FEMA briefing and he
just walked out in mid-speech like I'm
done here and they had to go fish him
out of the crowd like dude show a little
respect you know well yeah I mean I I
personally think that dog could be on
Capitol Hill giving some encouragement
to people that come to some agreement
well I was going to say well the dog has
just picked up eight votes to be speaker
so don't rule out the dog just yet he's
now in the lead he's the uh candidate I
thought George Santos just added that to
his resume
Jimmy okay back to New Year's now it's
it's that time of year again where
people are thinking about shedding a few
LVS but what happens they stop trying at
what beginning of February according to
the Wall Street Journal saying that
exercise and weight loss the common
focus is for resolutions but two-thirds
of the people who just basically
abandoned them in the first month Jimmy
how's how's it going for
oh a guy like you need to lose weight
yeah you look great no I've leaned into
this overweight figure skater look that
I rock on your show every year I look
like I used to be the gold medalist guy
they hoisted at the end of the routine
but now I got fat during covid so I'm
the guy on the bottom but stick with me
Laura the reason resolutions go nowhere
is people want to make them at the
beginning of the year to get the social
currency of posting the photo like look
at me I'm turning my life around but the
truth is nobody's heart is into it
number one number two you're making it
at a bad time of the year it's the
height of all the Ravelry which is the
holidays it's the winner so you want to
get it wait yeah
they're telling me I have to get out but
you just got thrown off by a mechanical
bull apparently he wants you to lose
weight or something Jimmy we'll see you
next week hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else